here we go [ __ ] Monday night
February 13th tomorrow night at this
time you either be getting your balls
licked or you'll be masturbating on some
chocolate and [ __ ] you take your pick
uncle Joey here if you're under 18 hang
up now [ __ ] uncle Joey's going off
tonight [ __ ] I got my favorite
[ __ ] Jewish person here
Lisa ah the wreck from [ __ ] Israel
ready to rock your [ __ ] night
we got the savage here we got a little
bit of some [ __ ] platinum cush put
your rock your [ __ ] world from
perennial and we're just doing our thing
you know I'm saying these are you in oh
yeah we got a big night ahead of us
leaves already sweating bullets
we got purple stars we got blood stars
we got Taffy's we got everything tonight
we're running the [ __ ] gamut
understand me so it's a good night for
you to show I hope you had a great
Monday the rest of the week is even
gonna be [ __ ] better I guarantee it
but let's take us two steps to the rear
and do a little [ __ ] tutu Lutz
[Music]
are you kidding me or what I'm like the
statue a smoke I can just stand here and
just blow [ __ ] smoke all day look hey
you go [ __ ] let's get the party
started
give me that bag uncle Li we got two
candles burning tonight one for the good
spirits and one for the [ __ ] bastard
look at this tonight look at this we got
star 125 milligrams this for my main man
he's taking that to go and we got the
stars a [ __ ] death but first
you know us we always open up with an
aperitif okay that's good one of these
wacky taffy together not like get
yourself one of these sleepers there's
like standing on a [ __ ] landmine
you'll lose a hand or leg something the
green apples are delicious they only
have two purples and cantaloupe prep was
a pretty good 200 milligrams you let
them get hard it's good for your teeth
your your jaws if you're not a dick
sucker but we have the kiss the stars of
death star one the sponsors of the 4/20
show up there Oxnard
March 20th 8 o'clock be there or be
square [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
nicely doc twins here oh you bad
[ __ ] we're filing a mountain
tonight we're gonna open up with seven
of them we're gonna have Lee sweat and
making noises so let's see let's count
these [ __ ] off believe one two
three three four five six seven ah ah
you bad [ __ ] this is like the
Sesame Street edibles when I [ __ ]
around here tonight no drama
they're fresh off the press ready for
the intestines tomorrow you wake up you
[ __ ] boom the high is gone you
understand me a lot of people don't know
that once you take a [ __ ] good morning
yeah I don't wanna take the shower
let your body stabilize I'll go eat some
Kiwi with your friends and you'll be in
business [ __ ] you understand me
the power of Christ is always compelling
you that's why we don't show up for the
church you're gonna be [ __ ] up
[Music]
I like early what else were you gonna do
to yourself tonight
watch The Bachelor with the black chick
what do you know do with your life huh
what the [ __ ] there's no football is
nothing you might as well hang out with
uncle Joey tonight smoke a few bong hits
get your life together maybe get a
notebook write your goals do what you
talk about what you want what the [ __ ]
are your dreams what do you really want
do you want to keep working the plumbing
supply house
[ __ ] loading shrugs in the winter you
want to get out there and be a
rockabilly [ __ ] star or something
tonight's your night get that notebook
write a song do something yeah I'm
saying it's better than sitting there
watching [ __ ] TV well you know that's
what America watches you to do they want
you to binge watch TV so you could be
[ __ ] like them [ __ ] that [ __ ]
we invented the [ __ ] TV we don't need
the TV we smoke read for the TVs in our
head and we write it down a piece of
[ __ ] paper what is wrong with you
[ __ ] it's time for another bong
hit of death here
this one's brought to you by lift you
understand me
go pick your friend up and smoke a
[ __ ] number and it's also brought to
you see so don't catch my special go
catch [ __ ] Mauricio Martin special go
cats and that live go clash that show
about the rental property see so brother
I got you [ __ ] tonight
[Music]
for second I'm sorry that bong had
[ __ ] up the whole thing
come on and let you be free damn time
little boys la woman one of the best
albums of our [ __ ] day today la woman
Jim Morrison dropped it on this
[ __ ] with Krieger and the boys
but enough with that [ __ ] how you people
feeling uncle Joey's here we had a great
week I want to thank you again for
making the [ __ ] CD number one around
the world without you guys I would have
dick I owe you everything
thank you very much in the bottom line
you know I'm very thankful and you guys
made my [ __ ] week everybody's happy
they don't know that we have a family
here it's tight-knit like [ __ ]
savages what tighten it [ __ ] group
bro
the church is gonna keep creeping and
creeping and creeping watch some guy
told me we're stuck at the airport there
they were the church t-shirt and a guy
from [ __ ] American Airlines bail them
out that's how [ __ ] much the church
has taken over little by little bro
because we're all from the same cut we
all got some rough edges but with
nothing but heart and balls were
misunderstood what the [ __ ] do you
expect and you do time is [ __ ] like that
but the hearts always in the right
[ __ ] place and it takes time to
convince people especially when you do a
little [ __ ] time you don't say any
stars you got left we got another one
there cuz I just need another one okay
we're going for 18 that's my call
Guinness tell them okay we got a new
record for the [ __ ] books alright ah
you bad [ __ ] you have no idea
my Uncle Joe he loves you with he and I
Monday night I could have been on an
early dinner with my wife for
Valentine's Day but I took the whole
family out we went to some Maria's
homemade spaghetti dinner mercy ate the
[ __ ] the spaghetti with the butter
and the olive oil I had the chicken
piccata
my wife had the [ __ ] bra Joel they
had bra Joel on the [ __ ] special time
was it he's close brush oh it wasn't
[ __ ] bad I gotta tell you something
Maria's family restaurant on Ventura
it's just a regular [ __ ] hole in the
wall nothing too fancy but you know what
it works because you're gonna get [ __ ]
around here anyway at least these people
are in the neighborhood the chicken
piccata was delicious I got the half
water you know I'm saying I'm trying to
watch the size of my ass boat but anyway
that's it nice that you and uncle Joey
let's do another bar Joe you're gonna
bore me to death with your [ __ ]
details
oh we're gonna spark the [ __ ] torch
your life Joey what I'm gonna do it he
is the amazing mr. Tom Rhodes fresh from
[ __ ] Tyler that's right taking pieces
little boys playing the drums naked yeah
I'm saying anybody tells me anytime so
he says I just came back from Thailand
and they smell like toys so I'm a righty
I'm saying
they smell like [ __ ] Hot Wheels some
a right [ __ ] you're still good
okay you wanna hit a liquid acid for you
with the sugar cube with the sugar I
know I know you did
no that's what we do guys for the
[ __ ] mental people that are really
mental they loved acid but nobody else
you know this is it
listen guys were all your [ __ ] treat
this is it the ice cube and the liquid
acid to three drops six seven hours to
get your head together you put on Black
Sabbath sabotage the answers will come
pick this down Santi many nights I was
there against the wall
oh and [ __ ] you put on the acid you
put on Black Sabbath sabotage the answer
will come to you who you gotta rob who
you gotta stab whose dick you gotta
[ __ ] put you [ __ ] it all come to
you cuz it came to me what do you think
should we do another bond arena here we
got one more left
and then mr. Rhodes is here I'm gonna
have another little Tecate is that
alright with you people we got a great
show tonight
[Music]
you don't see that type of fog in London
[ __ ] up that's what uncle Joey brings
you I take you away you [ __ ] anyway
we'll be back in ten minutes
youtube.com slash C slams Joey Diaz my
main man Tom Rhodes always [ __ ] a
great podcast always this guy's a World
Travel I live whatever through him you
know I'm saying I lived through him cuz
I got I got no passport so he tells me
about all these exotic locales he's met
Nazis the whole [ __ ] thing was the
real field he tracked with three Nazis
in Berlin one night when he hunted them
it happens here we go one of the
greatest songs ever written in my
[ __ ] world you understand me
beautiful three different verse changes
just one of the most brilliant
heartwarming songs I ever heard when the
first ones married when I got off that
[ __ ] plane from Cuba dog my mother
loved Jim Morrison she would tell me she
wanted to suck his dick and she put this
outline and I lose my [ __ ] this is just
something if you don't have a la woman
shoot yourself there on the beach now
they on the beach dog there are the
[ __ ] beach they just twist and
drinking wine coolers is [ __ ] that's it
this is it this is good as it gets
then he changes it up on you like three
or four times I'll let you guys go the
church ten minutes you see you then stay
black Tom Rhodes in the house
[Music]
the best the greatest [ __ ] see
intent are just another lost angel cilia
nights oh [ __ ] it's getting ugly in here